thank you thank you do you rock haven't
been inspired to make a ramped one-off
video in a long time but some of the
best ones that ever have come in in LA
and and Here I am again just enough
[ __ ] enough enough like living by
somebody else's rules is a humongous
mistake I just literally sat down with
five people under the age of 27 and it's
so [ __ ] refreshing it is so
refreshing if you have not jumped on the
bandwagon of doing exactly what the [ __ ]
you want to do which is skiing for next
three years or working at a job that's
not what your parents want or what
society wants this video is just called
enough enough make this little [ __ ] 1
2 minute video depends on when I finish
the piece of content that gets you to
[ __ ] stand up and take life by its
throat do something stop being [ __ ]
scared stop letting the way you were
raised the fear as an offense take that
away let me be the person I'll take the
blame I loved that some of my employees
are like my parents don't love what
you're saying good [ __ ] parents
because if you are playing defense and
if you are living a life where your kids
lives are the way you're being fulfilled
you're a [ __ ] loser parents and so
enough enough parents imposing their way
you want your kids to be happy on your
terms enough the kid that's sitting
right now in a desk and saw this in a
feed and you hate your [ __ ] job
[ __ ] enough stand up get the [ __ ] out
of here and do you live your life you've
got one [ __ ] life do something about
it
like so hard